if you consider ourself to be a factory
then the paroxysm inside the cell which
is basically a micro body and cell
organelle is compared to the recycling
center of the cell so just like a
recycling center recycle important stuff
and get rid of unnecessary stuff
paroxysm is used for similar purposes
and in this video we would look at the
structure function and the molecular
details of paroxysm so paroxysm is
thought to be produced from ER itself
now let's just talk about the overall
function of peroxisomes so first of all
paroxysm is an important site where
catabolism of long-chain fatty acid take
place and also branching fatty acids D
amino acids and poly amines are
catalyzed in the paroxysm secondly the
reduction of reactive oxygen species
takes part that takes place in the
peroxisome because peroxisome has an
important enzyme known as catalase and
in a moment we would look at that in
details other than that biosynthesis of
plasma Lochan happens in the paroxysm
and plasma leucine is so important for
our nervous system especially for our
neurons other than that so approximately
10% of the total enzymatic activity for
important for pentose phosphate pathway
happens in paroxysm it turns out that
important enzymes of Quintos phosphate
pathway are present in the paroxysm and
lastly people still debate and
scientists are still not sure but people
think that isoprenoid and coalesced
cholesterol can also be synthesized
inside the peroxisome because the
synthesis machinery is present there so
it's still debated but we'll take a look
at at least the three functions three
top functions in lot more details so
first of all peroxisome contains
reducing enzymes I just
Attalus and it has many oxidase enzyme
as well so oxidation catalysts enzymes
are the key enzymes present in the
ribose in the inner paroxysms now the
enzyme oxidase would basically oxidize
the any long-chain fatty acid or d amino
acid etc ultimately give rise to h2o 2
now here are is basically could be a
long fatty acid chain or could be amino
acid D amino acid chain as well but the
main thing is the h2o 2 the h2o 2
production is not good for the sale
because h2o 2 is also in the reactive
oxygen species somehow this h2 o2 need
to be converted into a less harmful
State let less harmful product and that
work is done by the enzyme catalase so
catalase catalyze the breakdown of
hydrogen peroxide to water and oxygen
and water and oxygen
none of them are harmful to the cell so
this is how the harmful substances are
recycled and broken down inside the
paroxysm apart from that the main
function of peroxisome is break down an
oxidation of long-chain fatty acids just
like mitochondria oxidation of fatty
acid also takes place in peroxisome but
there is some basic difference between
the two in peroxisome acetyl co a is
produced but the problem is the acetyl
co a is not coupled with the acetyl co a
is produced but this process does not
yield ATP just like happen in
mitochondrial beta oxidation but this
acetyl co a which is produced is an
important recycle recycled product
because acetyl co a is at the center of
many catabolic and anabolic pathways you
can see in this picture from ketone body
production to fatty acid production
cholesterol biosynthesis to phospholipid
biosynthesis in many of these process
estelle co is so important and that is
generated inside the peroxisome as well
and that could be used by this
to produce several other metabolic
products in that respect peroxisomes
function is pretty important now let's
just talk about how does plasma logic
synthesis takes place in the paroxysm so
the peroxisome has all the important
enzymes which is which is important for
initial step of production of the plasma
lajjun so plasma lajjun is produced from
a dihydroxyacetone phosphate or DHAP and
by a sequential step it forms one alkyl
g3p which gets transported into the
endoplasmic reticulum and the successive
steps happen in the endoplasmic
reticulum
so both paroxysm and in the plasma
critical them takes important part for
synthesis of plasma legions which is so
important for the nervous system itself
especially for its detoxification and
recycling function peroxisome is
important for liver and kidney because
most of the xenobiotic and harmful
compounds are detoxified in liver and
kidneys so peroxisome in liver cells or
kidney cells are very important now let
us talk about how these peroxisomal
enzymes are actually transported to the
peroxisome and it's an important
mechanism so as expected this is encoded
by the genes inside the nucleus which
transcribed to produce the mRNA of these
enzymes and this mRNA goes out and on
the ribosome present on the endoplasmic
reticulum membrane the protein is
translated and folded inside the ER now
once it is in the ER it is then
transported to the peroxisome now any
protein or any enzyme which is
transported to the peroxisome has an
important peroxisomal
target sequence or pts now this
peroxisomal target sequence helps to
target the protein towards peroxisome
and there is important translocon
channel on the membrane of the
peroxisome known as spec 17 which is
helping
peroxisomal target sequence containing
protein to get inside the paroxysm so
let's follow the peroxisomal target
sequence continuing protein here let's
say this is a oxidase enzyme which is
needed in the peroxisome so this
paroxysm targeting sequence would
eventually bind to peroxisome targeting
sequence receptor or PSR now this PT SR
interacts with pic 17 channel and allow
this enzyme which is knit which is
required to be delivered into the
peroxisome to get inside the paroxysm
and that is how for up delivery of or
targeting protein into the peroxisome
takes place now several diseases such as
adrenal leukodystrophy is a x-linked
disease which is occurring due to the
dysfunction of peroxisome so peroxisome
function is pretty important
now peroxisomal oxidase is actually
helping to convert the Launcher fatty
acid to acetyl co itself right now these
a oxidase enzyme need to be delivered to
the peroxisome at the first place right
but the ADL gene basically codes for one
particular translocon protein this
translocon protein is actually helping
the oxidase enzymes to get inside the
peroxisome now in case of the mutated
ABL gene what happens is the mutated
gene can no more produce the translocon
protein and as a result the important
oxidase enzyme cannot enter the
peroxisome as a result the oxidation of
long-chain fatty acid does not take
place in that disease situation as a
result the symptoms are destroy men ttle
so this is how peroxisome is super
important for our body and for our
cellular physiology now in plants don't
have peroxisome but they have a very
similar structure known as fly oxygen
to zone function in similar way just
like paroxysm does so it's a hub for a
fatty acid oxidation in case of plants
as well now beside paroxysm unlike
function glyoxal is also very important
for glyoxylate cycle in plants and that
is how a similar structure which is in
plant is also very important in terms of
plant physiology so I hope you enjoyed
this video and if you like this video
give it a quick thumbs up and don't
forget to Like share and subscribe and
make sure you comment on this video that
how do you like this video thank you